في مقطع فيديو متداول لفنان العرب محمد
عبده عامل تفاعل كبير جدا بين السعوديين
على المنصات خلينا نشوف مع بعض مقطع منهم
واا
هذا الوطن الذي وجدني يتيما
[موسيقى]
بظهره
وطعامتني
[تصفيق]
ثمرها
افرشت لي
[تصفيق]
ا ظلالها
[موسيقى]
من هالارض
انا
منها الان
منها
[موسيقى]
اللي مالي عيالها
غيرها
[موسيقى]
الفيديو اللي شفته كان اثناء تكريم فنان
العربي محمد عبده بجائزه التميز الاعلامي
لليوم الوطني 2022 بنسختها الثالثه وخلال
التكريم فنان العرب غلبته المشاعر ودموعه
وخنته الكلمات ولم يستطع التعبير من بعد
ما قال هذا الوطن الذي وجدني يتيما ونحن
في تفاعلكم نوجه له التحيه للفنان محمد
عبده ومن بيرك له على التكريم واكيد محمد
عبده كان وما زال اللحن والصوت الذي اطرب
كل العرب
[موسيقى]